un nouveau derby sulfureux entre
maurepas et guyancourt après s'être
quittés sur un match nul 2 buts partout
en novembre dernier et deux équipes se
retrouver sur la pelouse des rouges de
guyancourt
après une première période équilibrée
l'aiguillon courtois marque juste avant
la mi temps
c'est un but qui nous qui nous mais bien
parce qu'on finit bien la mi-temps donc
du coup on a on a su à ce moment là
justement appuyer où ça faisait mal et
marquer au bon moment vraiment un très
bon mois au retour des vestiaires
l'aiguillon courtois font le break suite
cette interception avant que maurepas ne
réduise l'écart sur penalty quelques
minutes plus tard c'est vrai qu'on était
à là dessus parce qu'on savait
qu'à 2 1 ça allait être compliqué et
qu'il allait s'accrocher jusqu'à la fin
donc malgré quelques situations chaudes
en défense et finalement guyancourt qui
aura le dernier mot
les rouges réussissent à convertir un
contre avec un peu de réussite
score final 3 buts à 1 on a su faire le
dos rond et bien résisté puis on savait
qu'en deuxième partie de saison on a 2
ème partie de la mi-temps pardon à avoir
les armes ou surtout offensivement et
physiquement pour aller chercher cette
victoire
quand on est dans le camp adverse au
moins ya des espaces qui se créent
d'arrière dans notre dos et voilà on a
pris les trois buts comme ça aujourd'hui
donc pas de regrets parce que voilà on a
joué on a eu un bon comportement
après voilà c'est des erreurs techniques
qui nous coûte sûrement le match
aujourd'hui
les deux équipes pourraient se retrouver
au mois de juin pour la finale de la
coupe des yvelines en attendant maurepas
deuxième ne compte plus que trois points
d'avancé sur son adversaire du jour